chers amis chers ennemis bonsoir
senneurs de rive droite rive gauche ce
soir le seul quotidien de la culture
vous propose une diff plein de modifs le
meilleur des meilleurs interview
diffusée depuis le début de l'année
je reçois maintenant la danseuse étoile
aurélie dupont bonsoir alors j'ai
remarqué que en fait en france il ya
deux dupont dans la danse c'est comme
chez hergé il y en a un avec un thé
c'est vous enfin une avec un thé et avec
un des ses patrick alors j'ai envie de
vous dire vous êtes très joli mais à
notre époque quand on dit une femme qui
avait jolie elle vous répond en général
c'est réducteur vous concernant ce jeu
c'est un très joli contrat bon vous êtes
vous ils vous me dites pas c'est
réducteur merci ceci étant c'est vrai
que vous n'êtes pas que jolis alors on
vous a en fait vous explique en a fait
un sujet sur sur carmen de roland petit
à l'opéra et puis bon là les formidables
manificat danse bien les belles et ou
alors on a dit on va l'inviter voilà
alors on va regarder un petit bout de ce
sujet et ensuite on discutera avec
aurélie dupont magnéto
m
[Musique]
voilà donc c'était aurélie dupont dans
carmen à l'opéra de paris chorégraphié
par roland petit vous êtes non seulement
jolie vous êtes belle quand on voit la
magnifique alors varier un peu de vous
de votre vie vous êtes né en 73
votre père était médecin à l'institut
pasteur ni toujours et toujours et vous
dites qu'il se consacrait à 101% assez
malade et c'est cette dévotion à son
travail que vous lui reprochez sans
doute un peu à l'époque finalement vous
l'avez en vous d'une la même façon j'ai
compris j'ai compris justement l'intérêt
qu'il avait pour son travail et pour ces
malades entre guillemets bien plus tard
parce que je fais évidemment pas la même
carrière mais c'est le même temps le
même la même notion d tu les mêmes
obligations les concessions tout ça donc
maintenant je le comprends mais à
l'époque les microprojets alors il est
parti vivre à ces jeunes aux états unis
vous étés majorettes alors ça quand même
c'est extraordinaire de voir ce que vous
auriez pu finir majorettes élan vouliez
être pianiste c'était une espèce
d'obsession chez vous vous étiez
toujours collé sur le piano comme ça et
vos parents ont pas voulu pourquoi je
sais pas je ne sais pas on en reparle de
temps en temps c'est vrai que j'avais
une passion ma première passion et l
piano j'avais 6 ans
j'étais fasciné par cet instrument je
jouais j'étais fasciné et je voulais
absolument de prendre des cours de piano
et je demandais un parent
continuellement acheter ce dont jamais
voulu je pense que les connaissant un
peu je pense qu'ils avaient peur que ce
soit un petit peu un
une envie subite est passagère et qu'ils
ont préféré justement ne pas nous avons
également d'offrir enfin et je ne savais
pas quel opiniâtreté nous avions alors
j'ai fait de la danse comme bosseur j'ai
commencé à dix ans il vous est présentée
à l'école de l'opéra
après trois mois de danse seulement et
alors là c'est incroyable avait mille
candidate et vous avez dix mois une
quinzaine de prise c'est très compliqué
de rentrée l'école de danse quand tu
quand j'ai commencé j'avais fait très
mode danse en effet donc j'étais assez
assez nul et je suis maintenant donc un
pur produit de l'opéra parce que j'avais
pas de je pense que l'opéra il préfère
parce que souvent les élèves qui
commence mal et petits-enfants qui
commence trop tout la danse prennent
souvent des défauts on essaie de gommer
après et ils préfèrent prendre des gens
qui peuvent hirsch de tout ce sont les
formes et de a à z vous souhaitez vous
avez été formés parce que donc
complètement remodelé dois je veux dire
des gens vont vous inculquer des choses
très dures et une psychologie d'une
personne de 20 ans mais déjà très
difficile et très jeune discipline de
fer c'est vrai qu'il ya un prof qui vous
forcer à monter sur des pointes avec des
semelles des faits j'ai eu des
professeurs un peu difficile je crois
que je ne sais pas si c'était moi qui
étais particulièrement sensibles ou ou
peut-être pas fait a complètement pour
cette école mais c'est vrai qu'on ai
fait ma première professeurs
à l'école de danse trouvé que j'avais
passé de force dans les chevilles est
vrai et ce qui était vrai à l'époque et
elle m'avait acheté des pointes avec une
semaine en faire évidemment je me suis
mis torse c'est complètement absurde et
j'ai passé mon premier examen avec une
entorse et vous mangiez aussi des choses
terribles sahour à 10 ans dans ça allait
super 14 15 ans que j'avais tendance à
être un peu plus un peu plus ronde ou
l'a 13 adolescents ça a été un peu
difficile à passer ou là je pourrais je
mangeais des 11 0% des blettes des
légumes et bradée et rien de très
excitant il ya des brimades danser dans
ces écoles en face aux derniers on
essaie une éducation dur par rapport à
au laxisme qui est la réducation
nationale aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile choix de l'école de danse et
un peu moi je compare souvent son
service militaire ça même rsa quand on a
15 ans on peut à la limite se comprendre
et puis on a fait on a déjà cinq 5
années d'école de danse derrière nous
donc on touche on touche au but mais
quand on a dix ans déjà de raisonner
comme un adulte c'est très difficile on
se rend bien compte et en même temps
l'assument qu'on n'a pas la même
éducation que les autres que les autres
enfin qu'il ya dix ans font bien
d'autres choses jusqu'à 16 ans
d'ailleurs est ce assez difficile et
séquoia l'embrigadement avait une
science ne prenez pas comme les autres
en même temps c'est un choix une passion
donc c'est un peu comme un sacerdoce
d'une certaine façon alors si tu y est
évidemment le petit rat qui veut devenir
étoiles se fait assez poétique je trouve
et à saison en 89 et admises au corps de
ballet de l'opéra on l'a déjà la
discipline se relâche un peu elle se
relâche parce qu'on n'a plus quelqu'un
derrière nous on va nous motiver à une
dictée un petit peu de ce qu'on doit
faire ce il ya une discipline qui est
qui est toujours là et qui est qui est
très présente et le problème le problème
qui est qui se pose c'est qu'on a on se
retrouve seul on doit gérer notre
carrière on doit gérer justement cette
discipline qu'on nous a inculqué pendant
six ans si vous l'appliquez après trop
trop freiné parce que parce que c'est là
où on peut perdre beaucoup de temps
alors à 23 ans vous êtes première
danseuse en 96 alors là il faut vous
m'expliquez parce que d'abord vous a été
soliste
il ya une hiérarchie quand on encore ou
alors c'est quoi comme coryphée par
exemple ça c'est un mot qui date d un
truc d'aller à la mecque la première est
la première classe vous êtes kadri
stagiaires pendant un an ce cadre quatre
stagiaires de dire quand vous êtes
remplaçant de tout le corps de ballet le
corps de ballet c'est l'ensemble et
danseurs qui sont bien souvent derrière
soeur étoiles qui sont l'allemand est
donc là vous apprenez tous les rôles
pendant un an ça c'est assez terrible
comme situation parce que on peut vous
demander cinq minutes avant de laver des
ruelles du rideau de remplacer technip
au pied levé donc ça c'est difficile
ensuite vous devenez kadri donc vous
avez le droit de passer des concours et
des concours internes chaque année une
sélection interne c'est très dur c'est à
dire sur 30 kadri par exemple il ya deux
ou trois places chaque année ce qu'est
ce qu'il est au dessus de kadri
qu'est-ce qui la prairie fait corrie
fait c'est ça voilà coryphée sujet sujet
c'est au-dessus de corps il fait partie
de korité ainsi j'ai première danseuse
ouais puis quand vous cette première
danseuse vous n'avez plus de qu'on
pourra passer vous êtes ou non nommé
danseur étoile voilà hélas hélas en fait
que vous pouvez devenir ou non et toi
voilà c'est prêt dans sa vie voilà
classique jusqu'à 40 ans l'âge à la
retraite alors vos rencontres ça a été
effectivement le disait roland petit
pina bausch qui était vraiment une
révélation en révélation pour vous je
vous disais pourquoi mon cru tant de
force les sphères ton corps accepte toi
comme tu es c'est à dire qu'elle vous a
apporté une certaine liberté mais pinasa
est une rencontre qui a qui m'a
bouleversé en tant que danseuse et en
tant que personne parce que bien souvent
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer des
chorégraphes contemporains bien souvent
c'est une rencontre technique est
formidable où une rencontre humaine qui
est formidable et c'est très difficile
c'est rare en tous les cas de trouver
quelqu'un qui nous apporte les 2 epinal
m'a apporté les deux c'est à dire une
technique contemporaine qui est très
difficile et qui mérite autant de
travail que les une technique classique
on a on apprend moins bien moins que la
technique classique et avec un apport et
n'a révélé que je vais parce que c'était
un peu triste j'étais déprimé ont fait
déprimer quand elle est alors là
mesdames messieurs le 31 décembre 1998
donc après don quichotte ugal s'approche
de vous et vous annonce que vous êtes
étoiles alors la ccc plus seulement
brillé par la technique c'est vraiment
se mettre au service du chorégraphe
qui faites-vous enfin vous et vous entre
entre la première soliste et le l'étoile
qu'est la différence en dehors du
plaisir que ça vous a fait je pense que
quand on est nommé dans ses toiles moi
la différence que ça m'apporte et c'est
juste un titre en plus c'est une espèce
de couronnes contre la tête ce soit
parce que vous réveillez lendemain vous
dansez pas mieux aux besoins des fautes
et je suis là je suis une étoile mais
vous êtes une étoile donc vous avez ce
titre suprême que c'est donc pour effet
l'équipe moi je vous admire beaucoup et
c'est bien ce que vous êtes étoiles
abbaoui une fille kate walsh est génial
mais je pense que l'étoile au sens
propre du terme se révèlent des années
après c'est à dire c'est vrai que j'ai
les mêmes défauts les mêmes qualités
j'ai une une maturité qui ce qui se fait
au fur et à mesure des années j'acquiers
une technique peut être un peu plus un
peu plus subtil et depuis non plus
j'aime responsabilité sur tout mais
c'est une responsabilité envers ceux là
mais vous un peu mais ça prouve qu'on
peut être dans ce film
évite quand j'ai le trac plutôt qu'un
bain chaud humble de dire je préfère une
nuit blanche un verre de vodka pomme non
ça c'est pas vrai c'est un article que
j'avais fait pour vsd je crois que je
peux dire
est donc l'article était était pas mal
et ils ont rajouté cette petite phrase
qui vient pas de moi j'aimerais la vodka
en plus donc ils ont absence mais il est
vrai que je suis pas contre un bon verre
de vin entre amis ou un bon resto est
bien la bonne heure il y à la bonne
heure alors dites moi on va terminer sur
quelque chose d'un peu plus people vous
m'en voudrez pas mais vous avez vécu
avec deux danseurs de l'opéra où je dis
vous dit j'ai envie de partager avec
quelqu'un qui soit étranger à tout cela
mais c'est difficile de la télévision je
ne sais pas c'est difficile toujours de
mai dans tous les milieux de vivre est
quelqu'un que tu fais mon métier vous et
c'est vrai que quand vous êtes nommé
danseur étoile et vous vivez avec
quelqu'un qui n'est pas forcément
étoiles ça peut mal se passer ou bien
sont assez concurrence pour moi ça s'est
mal passé mais mais c'est vrai que c'est
beau chercher plutôt cac 40 hors du
milieu de la bande qui me change la tête
d'accor très bien bas je pense que je
fais beaucoup de coutume épisode moi de
vous le dire mais vous allez il ya deux
deux femmes deux filles en ce moment
fantastique et hélène grimaud la
pianiste être qu un talent fou et très
belle vous vous êtes très belle aussi
vous avez beaucoup de talent et les
dieux vous en vraiment enfin des faits
se sont vraiment penchés sur votre
berceau parce que vous alliez la beauté
du talent alors on nettoie là on nettoie
la vie chère que maintenant vous êtes
étoiles pour le restant de vos jours tu
étoiles j'aime ma région je serai oui on
meurt ex danseuse étoile oui je serai
avec toi jusqu'à 40 ans à 40 ans on me
demanderait gentiment pas d'accord
épidémie chassieu on meurt et oil beds
étoiles ne meurt pas je reçois
maintenant le philosophe andré
glucksmann pour la parution aux éditions
nil de la troisième mort de dieu bonsoir
vous alors en vitesse avant de passer
aux bouquins philosophe vous dites que
vous au départ vous preniez pas
spécialement pour un philosophe parce
que le fait de faire des suivent des
cours et à ces examens ne qualifie pas
qu'il ya pour vous une quinzaine de
philosophes dans l'histoire de
l'humanité avec enfin comme le terme est
attribué à beaucoup de gens finalement
vous l'accepter c'est ça oui je suis
rien août oui
oui bon qu'à ça comme disait beckett
alors nouveaux philosophes en revanche
ça vous revendiquez pas du tout parce
que vous dites que c'est lui qui avait
appelé une collection comme ça mais puis
ça commence à faire ouaip eu beaucoup de
temps à l'oreille je suis un peu vieux
nouveau
bien alors le livre c'est la troisième
mort de dieu chenil alors prenons les
choses d'une façon très claire la
première mort c'était bon sur la croix
il ya deux mille ans la deuxième c'était
quoi alors la deuxième c'est la mort
dans les livres au 19ème siècle
essentiellement avant aussi après au 6
mai nietzsche marx michelet en gros dieu
est mort parce qu'on l'a tué lorsqu'on
l'a remplacé c'est l'idée de
remplacement qui est la plus forte on le
remplace par quelque chose à la crête du
peuple le culte du surnaturel excellent
fin ou la race ou daghlas de l'humanité
ou d'une visite que jean paul ii a tordu
le cou à cette mort d'une certaine façon
parce que dans sa son encyclique
négliger d'après-vous fides et ratio
le pape en fait déclaré cette querelle
un peu raison fois un peu obsolètes
parce que c'est ça oui oui les 2 sont
malades oui des mairies sans même temps
alors
la troisième mort c'est le 20ème siècle
nous y sommes c'est à dire les plumer
si on vous dit c'est verdun stalingrad à
auschwitz kigali grossemy quoi voilà une
grosse nice et aujourd'hui c'est le
massacre général et l'incapacité des
autorités morales et religieuses de s'y
opposer soit elles bénisse les canons là
où tu es de poutine avec le soutien des
orthodoxes du métropolite les canons les
avions qui bombardent les bébés
tchétchènes qui rasent une capitale ce
qui n'est pas arrivé dans l'espace
européen depuis varsovie et rasé par les
nazis quand même et bien c'est bénie par
l'église et puis mais yahia pas clair il
ya les tueurs en algérie qui tue au nom
de dieu et en tant qu au nom de dieu on
tue dieu et c'est ça à la mort de dieu
aux 20e et au 21e siècle c'est la mort
dans la boue dans le sens dans les
larmes c'est ça l'histoire réelle on dit
que dieu disparaît à cause de
l'émancipation des femmes de la
sexualité libre etc mais ça c'est pas
vrai il ne disparaît pas aux états unis
aux états unis en vie en dieu il n'ya
que l'europe où l'on vit comme si dieu
n'existe pas oui c'est ce que vous avez
un article de newsweek il disait dieu
est mort en europe oui et puis yahya
yahya le pape qui a ri les européens
vivent comme si dieu n'existait pas
alors il n'a pas dit de gaieté de coeur
il l'a constaté vous vous avez compris
des camps guerre à ces jeunes que
l'agitation ça paye parce que quand vous
avez été arrêté avec votre mère
vous étiez partons pour l'allemagne et
votre mère à la c'est fantastique cette
histoire-là hurlaient elle a hurlé
contre les gendarmes français qui vous
avait arrêté
et là qu'ils ont vu ça ils ont dit oui à
la rumba les on va les virer parce que
sinon ils vont contaminer les autres
sinon cette espèce de révolte va
finalement se propager dans les autres
juifs qui ont été arrêtés mais votre
mère a gueulé les autres vont laisser
sortir vous avez compris donc que
l'agitation ça paye je ne savais pas non
mais je connaissais pas cette histoire
il se trouve que c'est ça j'essaye de
comprendre pourquoi vous pourquoi vous
êtes comme ça et c'est vrai que non
seulement vous avez été élevé vous avez
été jeunes enfants au coeur du mal et
vous avez vu très tôt l' la capacité la
force de la rébellion la réaction mouais
j'ai été sauvé par des femmes alors bon
ma famille j'avais des soeurs aînées et
ma mère
ma grand mère elle avait 84 ans elle a
décidé de se laisser mourir parce que se
trouver encombrantes ne parlait pas
français ni nazi bon ça aussi c'est une
certaine forme de remises et puis j'ai
retrouvé les femmes algériennes paraît
quand même ne pas porter le voile et
s'exposaient à avoir la gorge tranchée
c'est une forme de résistance absolument
admirable qui m'émeut toujours je vois
les femmes tchétchènes elles sortent de
deux tchétchénie et arrive en ingouchie
sous la source ou le fusil des russes et
puis les russes c'est vraiment pas
tendre il casse vraiment tout ce qu'ils
peuvent casser d'abord les hommes aussi
les femmes à l'occasion et elles
commencent à protester elles résistent
elles sortent des pancartes disent toute
la vérité pleurs elle cherche des
caméras elle s'exprime et tout ça mais
vraiment sous la botte d'une armée et
donc je trouve qu'il ya là une
résistance qui est fantastique et mon
livre c'est une sorte d'hommage à cette
capacité dans la pire des situations
de résister alors avant 14 les gens
pensaient qu'il y avait un ordre suprême
qui aller les sauver oui bon aujourd'hui
il ne le pense plus mais sont pas
désespérée pour cela et c'est ça que
j'admire alors avant de vous avant de
vous on sépare nous poser deux questions
rêveur non de questions il ya d'abord on
a reçus ici en snow ltte
vous connaissez son bouquin la guerre
civile européenne de 1917 1945 alors il
ya eu plusieurs positions par rapport à
ça il y avait une première première
étape si vous voulez où on disait
finalement
le nazisme c'est très grave et le
communisme était excusé en raison
d'abord du fait que tout le monde en
france avait été assez de vie au
communisme et puis surtout des idéaux
nobles du départ ensuite il ya eu ce que
j'appelle l'époque des nouveaux
philosophes c'est à dire il claires
égales staline stalinisme et galgal
communisme c'est la même chose dans la
lignée d'un arrêt est aujourd'hui ian
holt et qui arrivent et qui dit et qui
sait le thème de son bouquin qui dit
finalement pas du tout le nazisme est
une réaction au communisme alors je
tiens j'aimerais bien avoir votre écoute
et c'est dommage qu'il n'ait pas eu à
inc quand même un auteur allemand bien
que juif ouais et heine déjà prédisait
que l'allemagne risquait il dit c'était
un avertissement française risquait de
pratiquer une révolution à la fois
révolutionnaire au sens un peu martys du
terme mais aussi nationaliste et
chauvine et xénophobes à 606 combien de
temps avant en 1919 il l'avait prédit en
19 en 1830 24 36 et donc pour vous la
théorie de heinze knowlton il est les
noms nagy c'est une théorie d'un culte
c'est une théorie qui dès qu banalise en
fait les crimes nazis bien sûr parce que
c'est par réaction il ya un fond
profondément germanique un fonds
profondément philosophique et en fait il
ya des racines communes mais c'est pas
l'un ou l'autre via des racines communes
et le sujet j'ai dans mon bouquin la
troisième mort de dieu un chapitre sur
lénine l'esprit du gué nisme qui va de
vladimir à vladimir c'est à dire que
poutine continue et c'est l'esprit
binaire un qui n'est pas avec nous est
contre nous si le tchétchène est contre
nous c'est pas un homme c'est un animal
un les lignes 10 rc
un insecte un insecte nuisible et que
disait hitler il disait ce sont des
rallyes donc il ya là une forme de
binarisme de pensée binaire qui reparaît
à l'état permanent c'est ça le léninisme
mais qui a inspiré karl schmidt qui est
le grand théoricien aussi du nazisme
mais donc vous n'êtes pas vous revenez
pas sur l'équivalence
nazisme c'est la même chose c'est pas la
même chose ils ont des moyens différents
une sauvagerie vraiment très parente
c'est à dire qu'au niveau des méthodes
ils les échanges c'est un peu comme les
islamistes et poutine oui ils échangent
leurs méthodes très bon et il s'inspire
les uns les autres c'est de la
concurrence mais c'est aussi du
partenariat
mais par contre la force du communisme
c'est de fait ce que vous avez dit à
savoir c'est au nom des bonzes idée
ouais alors est-ce que c'est mieux ou
est-ce que c'est pire quand on annonce
parce que la capacité de tromper est
beaucoup plus forte dans le commune ce
serait plus pervers d'une certaine façon
en un sens c'est plus universel
hitler il n'aurait pas pu étendre son
mythe de la raf chinois ont été
enfin alors que le commune ça puisse
s'étendre aux chinois huawei c'est très
universel en dernière chose jean paul ii
ça aussi c'est important ce qui s'est
passé la semaine dernière en israël
il a quand même aidé à dézinguer le
communisme il a quand même réconcilier
je dirais d'une certaine façon les
catholiques et les juifs est ce que me
crois pas que tu es mort lui non mais il
dit quand même une chose tout à fait une
nouvelle qui pourrait être à la limite
là je vais choquer quelques catholiques
mais pas tout ce que l'église est mortel
ou du moins qu'elle est capable de péché
mortel et ça je trouve ça absolument
remarquable c'est un périple personnel
il était jeune homme à cracovie il s'est
bien conduit la saison fut bien ce bien
sûr mais c'est évident qu'il se reproche
quelque chose parce que quand ils
canonise les gens et qanooni ceux qui
sont allés jusque dans l'enfer pour
sauver ou bien pour partager le sort des
juifs donc il se reproche quelque chose
et personne ne peut
reprocher ça vraiment il dit que
l'église est une construction humaine
donc elle est par définition perverti
sable et alors ce qui est nouveau c'est
qu'il accepte que
jadis l'église jugeait les gens quand
même de très haut du point de vue de
dieu il accepte que l'église soit jugé
de très bons vins du de l'extérieur du
point de vue du sang de la boue des
larmes et ça je crois que c'est
totalement nouveau en europe 1 ça vaut
pour la pour la religion ça vous même
pour les banques suisses qui a et qui
accepte tout à coup de se sentir pas
très propre et c'est ça vous pour la
social démocratie suédoise qui tout à
coup se rend compte que la castré des
fans parce qu'il n'était pas dans
l'ordre donc il y à une un effort pour
penser le monde un peu avec une échelle
de richter de l'uni l'inhumanité vous
savez quand il ya des tremblements de
terre on 10° 5° 6 mai il est mesuré à
kwal degrés il est mesuré à la pire des
catastrophes alors pour nous la pire bon
catastrophe en un sens c'est à aux juifs
mais ça nous sert à comprendre d'une
part les grandes catastrophes humaines
du style sebrenica etc ou du style
rwanda il ya vraiment un génocide mais
aussi les grandes douleurs personnel
vous allez dans dans mon livre je cite
visuel qui dit au fond un homme qui perd
sa fille après auschwitz qui n'est pas
juif qui n'est pas concernée par 8 voix
à une douleur qui est différente de
celle d'avant ensuite parce que dans le
regard de sa fille de son fils va
regarde de celui qui disparaît il voit
en un sens la fin de l'humanité donc sa
douleur est encore plus profonde si vous
voulez nous avons appris que nous sommes
mortels ça ne rend pas optimiste ça ne
rend pas pessimiste ça rend responsable
je reçois maintenant l'écrivain fernando
arrabal pour la parution chez plon de
portée disparue arrabal bonsoir bonsoir
quand vous étiez enfant devait remporter
un concours réservé aux enfants surdoué
c'était premio des soupapes dota tôt
mais vous savez c'est la savoie cet
accident de ma vie non mais j'étais un
accident qu lui puisqu'il était et des
filins condamné ouais et une bonne chère
m'a préparé pour avoir les titre
national les chiffres doué et j'ai loué
vous l'avez remarqué quand on voit ce
que vous avez fait après ils s'étaient
pas courir à manger pas cher et méritait
pas ils tous alors on va commencer par
d'abord je sais pas pourquoi je commence
par les arts plastiques j'aurais pu
commencer par autre chose alors votre
créativité donc se manifeste d'abord à
travers les arts plastiques sculpture
peinture collage dessin exposition est
respectivement le monde entier on passe
au roman douze romans recueils de poèmes
6 et ses épîtres 16 livres pour
bibliophile 150 longs métrages films de
long métrage de cinéma cette pièce de
théâtre 70 ça tient sur 19 volumes et
vous êtes je pense aujourd'hui l'udc
sans doute l'auteur de théâtre le plus
joué dans le monde plus que plus que
beckett plus que ionesco parce que mes
camarades mes collègues et 1 et mason
est modeste en pl non mais c'est la
vérité ils sont morts alors qu'ils
suivaient à la à leur place je suis
invité un peu partout vous passez votre
temps à faire le tour du monde vous
allez voir toutes vos expositions vos
pièces c'est tout et alors ce qui est
très étonnant c'est quand vous avez
choisi de vivre à paris il ya très
longtemps et quand vous êtes à paris
vous faites la critique des échecs pour
lexpress mu depuis 25 ans et plus depuis
25 ans les faits cette chronique des
chèques symboliques philosophiques
chronique littéraire et je dirais merci
à ce journal qui regardent ces
chroniques si c'est compliqué que vous
êtes à l'express quoique si vous êtes le
seul qui est là depuis 25 ans je suis
dit oui alors vous dit une chose dit si
j'avais eu le physique de gary cooper
j'aurais pas fait autant de trucs il
faut dire que pendant très longtemps il
était très angoissée par mon physique
j'ai pensé qu'il était le plus grand
monde c'est pour cela que tant dans les
groupe surréaliste mais il fait réaliser
des portraits des mois parce qu'il me
considérait comme on sait maintenant que
le temps passe
bien vous êtes très bien non écoutez
ça va quand vous êtes assis alors
vous dite ravie ma vie est un conte de
fées comme tous les contes de fées elles
commençaient mal mais elle finit bien
oui et c'est vrai qu'elle commençait mal
c'est dans le sujet de votre livre porté
disparu chez plon qu'est consacré à
votre votre père alors vous gardez de
votre père un souvenir très très
bienvenus rien du tout parce que vous
vous souvenez de lui vous caressant
enfin les chevilles en été sur la plage
et puis après il a disparu alors je
raconte un peu puis après on va en
parler plus sérieusement il a été arrêté
en 1936 votre père habitait à l'époque à
melilla alors évidemment portés disparus
sien ni mort ni vivant et vous dites si
j'étais sûr que mon père était mort il
aurait cessé de me hanter alors le
bouquin est assez facile à lire je le
dis à mes amis téléspectateurs ont ceci
très facilement il faut pas penser que
c'est compliqué il ya des passages
écrits à l'époque
vous avez commencé votre votre quête il
ya des dialogues théâtre ou y ait des
rapports de police il faisait même fait
un site internet pour pour retrouver
votre père mais sa vie on fait un signe
on fait ainsi check historiens parce
qu'il a été niée
gommer des l'histoire ma famille et par
les gouvernements par les facistes par
l'histoire et subitement il y as in
artistes et allemands qui a fait un site
si mon père et on peut s'adresser à lui
et on peut trouver des photos de tous
ceux sans qui ce qu'ils m'ont entouré
pendant qu'il était en prison alors de
raconter l'histoire vous est né à
melilla lors il faut dire à nos amis
médias c'est une bizarrerie de
l'histoire il ya deux violonistes
malraux nizhny à melilla et ceuta qui
sont des villes espagnoles sur la côte
méditerranéenne du maroc à un flic en
afrique un peu comme si on rend ou alger
était resté français qu'un type qui a
écrit un bouquin que ça je me souviens
plus de son nom je suis désolé pour lui
s'appelle les président je crois que
c'est au seuil et qui raconte c'est une
uchronie et qui raconte l'histoire de
oran et alger restons français
apprécient des pardons et thème précis à
ces ip m'aider il ya là s'est déprécié
dans la ville des milliers à la guerre
civile espagnole ne commence pas réussit
duilhé communiste ou de livres
d'histoire mais la veille et mon père
était militaire mais en même temps est
un peintre et il était fait son tableau
comme tous les après midi avec son
assistant et en rentrant on lui dit
qu'elle a suivi les commencer par
accident amélie parce qu'il faut dire
les gars il pour que les gens
comprennent bien c'est la réaction de
l'armée face à l'aca c'est la république
c'est un coup d'état militaire le coup
d'état militaire m et comme c'est énorme
plein de charme et mon père ont
l'enferment dans la salle des drapeaux
avec l'espoir qu'ils changent d'opinion
il est resté pendant trois chaises dans
la salle des drapeaux des militaires
heroes et 300 des transferts il évident
non ici pour la liberté pour la
démocratie et ne serait pas avec nous
mais on lui a dit muchacho gars sont
motivés des risques et à huy ça fait
rien alors dans la famille évidemment on
porte le deuil vous malti crêpes tout de
suite dé l'aider l'évasion son nom est
proscrit les photos sont de lui ils sont
découpés un peu à la façon de béria en
urss à l'espagne et blé chez moi qui
vous monte charge de chair à regarder ça
c'est un cadeau qui nous a faits qui m'a
fait et c'est une maison des poupées de
ce qu elle c'est un travail des
prisonniers et là c'était cuit sous lui
en toi et ton père parce qu'ils étaient
prisonniers et on a gommé st you know me
souviens toi et ton père et lorsque le
soleil espagnol as frappe pdci il sera
venu le monde
alors je jouerai continuer fernando
parce que l'histoire est pas finie vous
vivez donc avec votre mère dans une
ambiance un petit peu étouffante parce
qu'elle n'est pas d'accord avec le lui
reprocher ça d'avoir brisé tout ça
finalement uniquement pour des idées
donc les reproches sont un peu rabâcher
vous êtes élevé dans la foi catholique
vous commencez un petit peu écrire il là
vous devez devenir officier de
l'aviation
vous aurez du et à 16 ans au moment de
prêter serment sous les draps pour vous
rebeller non pas par antimilitarisme si
vous avez peur de l'avion et là ça a été
le début de votre grande rébellion
que tout le monde connaît qui est
célèbre qui s'est appliqué dans plein de
domaines
révolte contre la société
révolte contre votre mère contre votre
physique contre le sentiment de la faute
en phase est devenu arrabal quoi oui et
j'ai essayé tout le temps des copié ces
moments donc quichottesque cette nuit
dans lesquelles mon père à féchy choix
et toute ma vie ici de reproduire ce que
l'on appelle éléments courage des
monades ah c'était ça il sait lire les
disques durs louis j'ai participé
évidemment au mouvement panique avec
topor et jodorowsky j'ai créé oui vous
êtes connus d'al hilal et rencontrer
john lennon un jour vous aviez faire ce
film merveilleux que viva la muerte et
john lennon est venu vous vous voir en
médicaments en sifflant la la musique du
film à lauris extraordinaire morrison
jim morrison est longue en 67 s'est
arrêté en espagne il ya encore franco
évidemment et vous êtes fier de ça vous
dit c'est le plus bel hommage qu'on
pouvait me rendre mon père absent
lorsque lorsque et imaginer qu'ils
étaient accusés
comment excuser les chars et de la
comparution comme socrate way pour
blasphème
mais ces retraités notamment pour délit
d'opinion et vous attend tous la même
lâché
insulte à la patrie mois
alors est ce qu'on peut dire pour
conclure pour finir le conte de fées
c'est qu'après bon et après franco il ya
eu juan carlos en votre frère lui a pas
du tout suivi la même voie que vous il
était à l'académie militaire où il a été
il a fréquenté juan carlos et son fils
le fils de votre frère et l'ami est
venue l'idée du prince des asturies et
sans dire comment dans une famille de
vraiment votre frère lui les compétents
dans l'establishment espagnol et vous
vous avez vécu cette vie
familiarité avec les rois d'espagne et
qui m'a fait l'honneur qu'il est prêt je
suis le seul à m'avoir intrusions ces
appartements matériel c'est tout
simplement parce que il y as a aussi
noté famille sauf son mari chez le roi
d'espagne lenski ce qui prouve son
intelligence et sa grandeur d'âme c'est
que justement il dit que votre votre
côté contestataire est utile à l'espagne
grand prix en espagne et il est là
précise avec les a les ministres avec
tout le monde avec des pirouettes et
égérie dit écoutez vous savez faire des
discours mais il veut pas faire un
discours je voudrais danse et d'un
moteur essence et leur un méli mélo
c'est et j'ai fait ces moments remplis
mauvaise la moins mauvaise conférence de
ma vie à la place de faire des discours
j'ai dansé tous les autorités espagnoles
comme aussi mon père les rennais
rattachés il ya plein d'histoires qu'on
n'a pas tendre à condé c'est le jour où
vous avez un pull overs et les manger
chez droit vous mettez un pull-over et
alors il vous dit monsieur vous mettais
une serviette de toilette avec un w sur
la serviette il vous dit c'est l'hôtel
winston lui dit non c'est l'hôtel vilu
reef est en effet voilà c'est lorsque
j'étais un au japon avec avec mishima
ouanna en amérique avec guise vélo en
france j'avais avec avec le britannique
réalise toujours j'essayais de trouver
ces contestataires ouais parce qu en
espagne avec une serviette de toilette
c'est vrai que c'est alors le roi pour
pour en finir avec lui un soir vous
dîner chez lui elle après le repas vous
fumer une cigarette dans un coin et
vient vers vous et vous dit tu me
boycott
et je les ai écoutés il ya quelque chose
de forme il peut lire non il m'a dit
mais vous voit vous voyez que c'est une
des pistes répression qui vouvoie je les
lis les lignes de la main et qui avait
appuyé ce qui à un moment donné mais oui
c'est ma cousine
élite alors je comprenais pas la reine
elizabeth ce qui est de l'araignée lice
avec ne payez pas ne voulait pas payer
des impôts ouais le roi lui a dit le roi
d'espagne la vie propice et je vis
majesté permettez moi de lire les lignes
développement et gelid les lignes je
n'avais vu quoi dans ces lignes là ils
avaient évidemment la ligne dentition
qui travaille peut-être vous n'avez pas
il reste à voir si vous l'avez les
lignes d'un tissu rare mais vous l'avez
je lai et oui vous l'avez la simple
pensée etc mais ce qui est grave chez
vous c'est la ligne d vous n'avez pas
lesquels l indice commencé parce qu'elle
n'avait pas des lignées caire c'est pas
de ma faute j'ai pas dean becker n'avait
pas et c'est très rare vous savez la
lignée des vies la ligne et
d'intelligence fait profond selon la
ligne et d'intuition qui est peut-être
rac la ligne de chance la lignée des
classes mais celle qui devait était ici
l'allier desquels vous ne l'avez pas ce
que ma faute vous devez vous savez
beaucoup changé je reçois ma temps la
comédienne virginie ledoyen pour la
sortie en salle de la plage virginie
bonsoir ça on s'est rencontré tous les
295 mais c'était ma première émission de
télé la première émission de télé je
faisais paris dernière on avait rendez
vous au trocadéro exactement dans le
froid il devient grand manteau demande
d'emmanuelle j'ai fait un peu mal élevé
je vous demandais si vous avez des sales
mjc tellement vous aviez avoué vous
fumez toujours autant
un petit peu moins mais toujours en
cours ouais toujours sacema vin pain qui
était pour vous à l'époque
alors vous êtes là pour ce qui va être
apparemment votre premier gros succès au
cinéma mais vous avez fait beaucoup de
films la plage sortie mercredi avec
leonardo dicaprio guillaume canet robert
carlyle alors le livre des parents avec
bébés nous parlait tout à l'heure du
livre donc un livre d'alex garland qui
est culte quel un livre va plus en
angleterre dire qu'aux états unis qui
est sorti en france c'est hachette
littératures alors vous l'avez lue après
avoir accepté ou avant après après un
très j'en avais pas du tout entendu
parler en fait et parce qu'effectivement
ça a été un best-seller en angleterre je
cours aux états unis mais en france je
ne savais pas et ouais si les jeux après
c'est pas très différent parce que le
film est différent du passé dans le film
quand même nom s'est passé baptisé mais
c'est toute façon de ce qui est écrit
dans le bouquin c'est un film à blond il
ya des choses qui sont pas qu'ils sont
pas filmés c'est pour ça que c'est un
film est pas un livre alors le pitch
comme on dit ici donc richard rencontre
françoise quitte avec etienne à bangkok
dans un hôtel pourri comme on en
connaissait à l'époque et ils vont dans
cette danse est il quoique d'une espèce
de baba landes
vous continuez qu'est ce qui se passe
une fois là bas mais une fois là-bas
d'abord c'est très compliqué d'y aller
ouais et puis ensuite ils finissent
finalement par y arriver et c'est assez
fantastique c'est vrai que c'est cool
c'est bien ils sont tous gentils
tout ce beau
et puis finalement c'est pas si bien que
ça
et finalement oui évidemment c'est le
paradis qui se transforme en enfer ou
alors ou alors c'est un apprentissage eu
de démarche un peu initiatique oui
complètement je laisserai elisabeth qu'à
nous faire la psychanalyse du film en
tout cas moi j'ai trouvé ça très bien
alors le réalisateur c'est danny boyle
café petits meurtres entre amis les
trainspotting là qu'il ya une s'est un
peu calmé quand même sur ce film ouais
mais je trouve que gili a un peu c'est
moins spectaculaire mais c'est en corse
et il ya toujours ce cynisme oui c'est
assez incisif malgré tout droit
hollywood ya un produit par la fox c'est
quand même assez incisif le casting ce
qu'on parle jamais de ça en fait à la
télé c'est à dire quand on vous voit
arriver vous les actrices comme ça on
dirait du pot ale temps avec dicaprio ou
est-elle en thaïlande pour moi en fait
bon il ya eu un moment où nous étions en
concurrence contre d'autres actrices
j'imagine on n'en parle jamais de sa
williams palpable c'était un casting il
est venu à part leur rencontre et il
connaît pas nécessairement très bien les
actrices françaises donc il est venu et
puis et puis on se voit puis on fait des
essais une première fois puis une
seconde fois puis on attend puissent
apprendre la semaine et puis on
recommence on vient et puis et puis on
vous saviez que vous savez qu'il était
en concurrence contre vous non non pas
parce que présente pour les roseaux
sauvages vous et c'est sur le coup vous
arrêtez ça c'est votre bouche s p gagné
non mais c'est terrible on se rend pas
compte en fait ça doit être des moments
terribles en vous je crois que là vous
vous tellement vous aviez le travail est
parti mais je sais qu'il en a tant pis
et puis on vous a appelé pratiquement le
lendemain vous disant cette menace est
parce que c'est vrai que ça prend
beaucoup d'importance et puis en même
temps on n'est pas on n'est pas
nécessairement le personnage mais on est
le personnage l'actrice que le metteur
en scène ravi d'avoir mais quand on sait
qu'il ya il voit cinq filles s'y fit
sans même savoir qui elles sont ça
devient très compliqué est ce que c'est
moi est-ce que c'est pas moi et donc ça
rend con
alors au niveau du cash chez vous a été
bien payé pour faire ça ça va ça va
leonardo il a pris un paquet lui quand
même
leonardo il a pris la moitié du budget
du film 20 millions de dollars soit 50
millions de dollars c'est bien il faut
quand même avouer un aller simple we can
pas des millions de dollars comme lui
non ça me suffit amplement
là c'est bien parti alors quand je
parlais du buzz qu'a eu sur le film tout
à l'heure c'est le tournage donc dans
cette île au large de phuket avec tout
le monde connaît l'histoire c'est la
production voulait a voulu raser des
dunes voulu replanter des cocotiers
jeu mais trop sale histoire c'est qu'en
fait ils ont trouvé cette île qui pipe
il y était une poubelle en fait il
voulait qu'elle soit complètement
encadré de rochers elle était
dégueulasse ils l'ont fait nettoyés ils
ont replanté des palmiers et les
écologistes locaux étaient pas contents
certains en fait on était une partie
était d'accord et suivait le tournage et
contrôler tout ce qui se passe est plus
une autre qui lisait le fait que ce soit
la fox et surtout dicaprio pour faire
une pub monstrueuse autour de soi tout a
été remis en état oui un oeil aux champs
de cannabis moi ce qui m'a le plus
fasciné je veux dire il a été planté ce
champ il était gigantesque
alors on nous a dit que c'était pas des
farfelus de cannabis avant j'en doute
mais la personne n'a essayé quand même
alors il était éclairé 18 heures par
jour pour que ça pousse plus vite passé
un court comme ça maintenant c'est
comment il faut faire pour l'herbe dans
son jardin il faut maintenir la lampe la
nuit par exemple bien alors vous dit en
parlant de vous que vous n'êtes pas une
bonne affaire pour les journalistes et
pour la presse dite moi je suis heureuse
j'ai eu une enfance heureuse japan hui
use pour la pour la presse c'est un peu
sans histoire d'une certaine façon
on essaye de vous mettre un peu une
image de deux petites origines modestes
on roule fait le coup parce que vous
êtes né à aubervilliers mais votre père
venait de la dass il travaillait sur les
marchés grand-mère concierge au rang des
autres dit tiens on va alors on va là
qu'habite cherche des étiquettes tout le
monde cherche toujours des étiquettes
donc les journalistes essayent de vous
mettre un peu dans cette catégorie mais
vous dites je ne suis pas cause est bien
que vous avez surtout le tourner avec
josé d'ailleurs mais non non c'est à
dire que c'est pas spectaculaire j'ai
pas ce qui est ce qui relève de mon
intimité samara ça m'amuse pas de la
raconter j'ai des parents que j'adore
qui ont été formidable avec moi qui sont
commis sont effectivement je suis pas la
plus jolie ville de france mais ça remet
enfin bon vous étiez gâtés comme j'étais
petit je n'étais pas spécialement
malheureux jet ski tout va bien je
partais à méribel citoyens
j'ai des origines sacha positions
rigides métis et du sang espagnol
espagnol noire qu'a dit ousmane en
espagnol alors j'imagine j'imagine
probablement arabe
mais non j'ai des tentes
j'ai deux tantes d'origine malienne des
cousins un kabyle enfin je sais pas
j'attends un grand mélange choix donc
avec l'agente partout alors y'a un truc
plus intéressant c'est que remercie
alors mes chers plus intéressant sur le
rapport aux origines modestes vous
concernant c'est à dire que fabrice
luchini michel serrault m'ont raconté
ici que ce qui avait été leur meilleure
école de comédie c'était la rue c'est
venu comme ça que je dis plus
intéressant puisque vous à l'âge de 15
ou 16 ans vous étiez sur les marchés
avec votre père et vous quand vous
parlez de vie vous dites c'était la
commedia dell'arte la façon qu'ils
avaient de vendre aux gens ça vous a
inspiré sa suis pas si ça m'a
certainement mais je trouvais ça
fascinant le le pouvoir de persuasion
que de marcher dans la rue d'avoir un
mec qui est là qui vous qui vous appelle
et décide de vous vendre un truc donc
vous n'avez peut-être pas besoin
nécessairement et vous repartirez avec
et je trouve que c'est un pouvoir de
persuasion phu bai luchini et serrault
c'est ça oui à la paix il se balader
dans la rue là bas woerth n'est pas mon
mari il faisait le conte dans la rue ce
héros aussi c'est comme ça c'est au
contact de la rue qu'ils ont appris à
jouer la comédie quoi je pensais alors
vous avez débuté à l'âge de 3 ans 1
dans des pubs
oui dans des pubs mais une pub je ne
sais pas une poubelle non non non je me
souviens pas bien j'ai fait des photos
mais c'était c'était des trucs
occasionnait j'ai dû faire de pub entre
3 ans et 6 ont après l'âge de 9 ans et
aide à l'école du spectacle exactement
et à 16 ans est partie de chez vous avec
eux commencé à amener votre vie à l'âge
de 16 ans mais c'est bien je ne sais pas
j'ai vraiment c'était bien parce que
c'était ce que j'avais envie mais j'ai
beau parent n'était pas inquiet je pense
qu'il l'était mais en tout cas ils ont
fait comme s'ils trouvaient c'est
absolument normal non parce que votre
premier casting enfin sérieux là c'était
mi mât avec philomène esposito vous êtes
allé tout seul l'âge de 13 ans au
casting alors que toutes les petites
filles étaient avec leur maman oui mais
je connais le métro pourrait à l'école
tout ça part très gelé huit ans donc
c'est un casting vous tapez n'est pas
rentré ça très bien je pense qu'il était
très fier mais en même temps je n'ai pas
non plus envie de passer leur vie hamish
a prôné m'accompagne au casting et c'est
donc si j'avais envie de retourner chez
vous vous dites voilà je vais faire un
film à ma patrie sacrée non alors il a
fallu que la production à peine mes
parents dire que c'était vrai mais assez
volontariste quand même quand vous là un
truc vous êtes oui un ouais je trouve
que
j'ai pas l'impression de pouvoir faire
les choses tout seul mais tout cas
j'essaye de me donner les moyens de les
faire donc ça marche pas toujours
il reçoit maintenant le romancier
philippe djian pour la parution chez
gallimard de verre chez les blancs
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous dit à la télé
je me trouve très mauvais j'achèterai
pas un de mes livres après m'être vu
dans une émission c'est mon éditeur le
premier mon premier éditeur bernard
barrault qui me disaient mais évite la
télé ils avaient raison sûrement mais
non vous êtes un peu gêné par la
promotion parce que vous dites que
finalement on se sert chez vous de
l'individu c'est normal en télévision
évidemment on ne peut pas dire des
textes etc en fait
l'individu s'est pas l'écrivain et que
vous dites en tant qu'individu j'ai pas
tellement d'intérêt finalement je trouve
qu en fait oui moi j'ai pas d'intérêt
mais je trouve qu'il ya peu d'écrivains
qui ont un intérêt en tant qu'individu
ce qui est intéressant c'est ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est pas pareil pour les
musiciens les acteurs non c'est
différent mais l'écrivain en plus c'est
vrai que c'est quelqu'un qui doit être
un peu caché si vous dites façon
l'écriture c'est quelque chose de tout à
fait normal
c'est pas plus important que doctor who
aux journalistes aux étés qui énervait
un peu par les écrivains qui pontifient
à la télévision devient drôle de manière
c'est à dire que moi j'ai tellement de
j'ai une vraie passion pour la
littérature de cette passion elle peut
fonctionner que dans la mesure où je je
redescends la littérature à un niveau un
petit peu proche de vous et de moi c'est
à ce niveau là que j'essaie de que les
écrivains qui pontifient m'énerve
littérature à doit être proche de nous
elle nous sert à quelque chose de
littérature donc en faire quelque chose
d'un peu abstrait ça m'intéresse pas
alors vous publiez donc vers chez les
blanc chez gallimard je signale aussi
que hassan bob qui sort chez folio
gallimard en poche puis de livre
d'entretiens donc je citerai les titres
à la fin de notre entretien
le titre alors ça vient d'où vers chez
les blanc
c'est un truc très bizarre c'est j'étais
en train de dans l'écrit j'en avais
écrit peut-être
une cinquantaine de pages et en allant
chercher ma fille qui a été chez des
amis il neigeait beaucoup et je suis ma
voiture est sortie de la route et je
suis tombé à la voiture s'est encastrée
dans un panneau et je vais vers chez les
blanc et là j'ai compris qu'en plus
c'était tout à fait ce qui est une
petite maladresse grammaticales que j'ai
que je trouve très très belle
vers chez les blanc c'est pas
[Musique]
la fin les personnages de la musique de
la phrase vous a séduit je trouve ça
très beau mais comme c'est pas de moi je
peux d'autant plus revendiquer la beauté
de la chose alors si le pitch comme on
dit ici donc c'est francis qui est
écrivain qui a perdu femme et enfant
dans un accident d'avion
et puis fait comme si elle était
toujours là d'une certaine façon et lui
suggère de faire un de faire entendre
c'est la façon la plus afin de faire un
film porno sa façon la plus triviale de
raconter l'histoire est ce que ça vous
va oui c'est un peu ça c'est en fait
c'est un homme qui a perdu sa femme et
ses enfants et c'est surtout sa femme
qui compte dans l'histoire c'est à dire
que au bout de deux ans il commence à
peut-être avoir envie de retourner vers
un monde un peu réel un peu vrai et en
particules de cendre sexuelle oui et là
donc
il a décidé de toute façon que sa femme
était pas morte parce que sinon lui il
n'existe plus donc elle n'est pas morte
et il se débrouille pour que ce soit
elle en fait dans un espèce de faux
dialogue mais qui est en fait en même
temps un vrai dialogue
ils se débrouillent pas que ça soit elle
qui le disent mais pourquoi pourquoi on
ferait pas un porno moi je fais du
cinéma en plus je pense que pour toi
c'est bien et surtout n'ai pas peur
c'est pas en faisant un parent d'optimum
trompé et des scènes très porno j'ai pas
le temps d'en parler penser commun quel
point je suis désolé gêné j'avais noté
quelques quelques pages
lui avoir parlé du pur de la
pornographie pardon on va en reparler de
la porno maryse ans maintenant par
exemple maintenant ce que j'ai pas le
temps de lire les noms je trouve que
c'est c'est une c'est un terrain qui est
très très sensible je trouve que c'est
très très attirant pour les écrivains
qui n'ont pas peur de moi j'ai toujours
été un petit peu écrivains dans la marge
un petit peu comme ça même nappe que
j'ai vu tout à l'heure donc on peut y
aller on peut essayer de d'aller vers
d'explorer des voies que les autres
écrivains qui sont des écrivains plus
respectables
n'essaye pas d'aller explorer donc moi
je trouve que c'est en plus une matière
très très forte il ya beaucoup de choses
à faire que c'est quelque chose qui est
près de ce que je vis moi parce que
quand on parle de l'érotisme je sais pas
ce que ça je comprends pas vraiment donc
la pornographie oui et je la revendique
d'autant plus que la pornographie telle
que je la vois dans les magazines ou
dans les films x du samedi soir je
trouve ça ne m'intéresse pas mais je
crois qu'il en est une autre et en plus
en tant qu'écrivain on doit être assez
fort pour
pour la prendre à bras le corps et en
faire quelque chose parce que moi je
crois qu'on peut faire quelque chose
avec ça alors votre vie bon ballon voilà
survolé mais il ya quand même un épisode
que ce soit absolument raconté donc il
sait turbo fac de lettres à vincennes
école de journalisme rue de rennes
dockers au havre vous dit vous êtes
toujours le crochet c'est vrai j'ai
toujours le crochet un pur oui
maintenant
bon bien un jour prendre un avion pour
la mesure vous travaillez à la librairie
française au rockefeller center
partez en colombie faire un reportage
avec un copain du lycée turgot sur les
guérilleros vous revenez essais refusés
par match et par l'humanité ça vous
dégoûte un peu du journalisme vous
bossez airtel vous couper des dépêches
rtl vous rencontré bruno masure vous
fait des interviews vous rencontré la
veuve de céline montherlant vous avez
fait la dernière interview de
montherlant avant son suicide et il vous
a dit d'ailleurs cette phrase mon succès
est un malentendu vous l'a répété comme
ça trois quatre fois parce que je trouve
que c'est très
j'ai l'impression que tous les vrais
succession de malentendus en fait vous
pas vous parler à 30 ans et à 37,2 quand
vous dites ça c'est à dire que ça vous a
marqué ben oui parce que c'est pas un
succès en fait le succès 37 oh c'est
vraiment le succès de jean jacques
beineix
qui a eu des millions de spectateurs
c'est pas moi qui les ai eus ces
spectateurs là c'est vraiment mais je
trouve qu'il a eu au moins
l'intelligence de s'approprier
l'histoire et ça c'est là que certains
metteurs en scène ont la force de le
faire s'est passé pas toujours évident
et oui donc mon succès à ce niveau là
est un malentendu commande est vrai que
tout ce qui a été mauvais tout les
mauvaises critiques et tout ce que j'ai
pu avoir comme problème avec certaines
pratiques c'est venu là en fait celui du
succès alors bon après vous bossez un
peu à détective comme les writers c'est
une bonne école puis bon c'est l'époque
d'un mouvement 68 on doit avoir à peu
près le même âge alors évidemment on
voyage on s'accroche à rien on veut
s'installer nulle part dire vous vous
avez continué quand vous déménagez
extrêmement souvent vous moi il ya un
truc mais je répète tout le temps c'est
une phrase de melville qui disait soyez
toujours fidèle au rêve de mettre je ne
serai et moi je trouve que c'est j'ai
des tas de défauts mais ouais je suis
toujours fidèle à ses rêves c'est vrai
alors à 25 ans et j'en arrive à ce que
je vais absolument raconter tout ça fond
des dames à 25 ans on ne voulait pas
élever votre votre enfant dans le béton
vous partez et vous devenez
péagistes était au travail dans un péage
sur une bretelle de l'autoroute paris le
mans à la ferté allais non infectés
bernard à la ferté bernard pardon je
connais pas et alors là à l'ordinaire
c'est xavier toute la nuit ça a duré
huit heures il veut de bagnols qui
passait parce que c'était une petite
bretelle d'autoroute évidemment et
laurent bontoux vous tous les gens qui
travaillent et vous et des mots croisés
lisais des polars et vous prenez une
machine à écrire sur les genoux et vous
écrivez 50 contre 1 qui a été votre très
bon tout ça génial ça oui mais toutes
ces histoires qui sont géniales en fait
elles sont elles sont géniales parce
qu'elles sont vraies et qu'elles sont un
peu folle ouais et je sais pas pourquoi
je pourrais pas vous dire pourquoi j'ai
pris une machine à écrire c'est parce
que j'avais plus envie de faire des mots
croisés écouter la radio et je me disais
mais il ya aussi un truc c'est que je me
suis rendu compte un moment que pour
vraiment écrire il fallait du temps et
je n'avais jamais trouvé l'occasion de
retrouver 8h ou 9h pour travailler
j'avais les tas de copains qui est
obligé de travailler pour faire vivre
leur famille moi c'était on me disait
tiens voilà faute à toute la nuit fais
ce que tu veux du moment que tu en mets
personne sans caméra ordinaire et alors
là bon vous finissez vous revenez à
paris
noël votre ami qui vont fait que vous
avez un peu conseillé d'écrire chez
gallimard est mort vous donnez le
bouquin à gallimard et tournier michel
tournier même si depuis il a dit que ce
n'était pas vrai dit enfin au comité de
lecture dit en parlant de vous il se
situe délibérément en dehors de la
littérature ce qui maintenant quand on
lui rappelle sa l'énervent m'enfin bon
et donc vous allez pas chez gallimard
vous allez chez barrault vous quitterez
quelques années plus tard après de
nombreux moulins de nombreux best
sellers mais parce qu'il a vendu à
flammarion sans vous le dire c'est ça
oui moi j'étais aux états unis et puis
j'apprends un jour que donc les éditions
bernard barrault sont en partie passé
chez flammarion
je n'avais pas envie d'être chez
flammarion donc mais peut-être parce que
c'était comme ça le mettre devant le
fait accompli c'était insupportable et
je sais pas j'ai beaucoup d'orgueil pas
comme individu mais comme écrivain je
trouve que les écrivains c'est pas des
gens qu'on doit prendre comme des
savonnettes et en faire n'importe quoi
donc je dis non je regrette à partir
d'aujourd'hui tu auras plus mes romans
mais sinon je serais encore chez bernard
barrault mois les assurés et là
maintenant vous êtes donc revenue chez
chez gallimard la boucle est bouclée
donc magasinier à 16 ans chez gallimard
est aujourd'hui un des auteurs de la
connu et qui vendent la maison alors été
publiée tout de suite et vous dites ça
m'a ça m'a évité de prendre du recul sur
ce que je faisais parce que c'est vrai
vous avez eu du succès tout de suite
quoi oui c'est pas non plus un bien je
me suis pour les avions sale en famille
c'est à dire que les je pense pas qu'il
ya une ligne que j'ai que j'ai pu écrire
qui n'ait pas été publié en fin donc
j'ai même pas eu j'ai pas eu de recul du
tout par rapport à la chose les
premières nouvelles moi je me souviens
j'écrivais ça pour des amis qui venaient
de paris me voir quand j'étais à la
ferté-bernard et c'était une manière de
les retenir en fait parce qu'il trouvait
ça drôle il trouvé ça amusant et quand
il venait passer le week end dans la
campagne le fait d'en parler le soir ça
animait les soirées je réécrivais là
pendant la semaine dans la ligne de
péage la nuit et quand il est arrivé le
week-end il y avait d'autres choses à se
mettre sous la dent alors moi j'ai pas
un slim à ce moment-là d'idées de succès
succès rate enfin supprimer des rapides
et puis aussi adaptation au cinéma
premier film qui a été tirée d'un de vos
livres c'est bleu comme l'enfer alors
bois c'est alors la différence je dirais
c'est que moi c'est lui il a acheté les
droits et puis vous sied pas tellement
occupé d'eux n'a pas vraiment appeler
méchant jacques non plus avant non
enfin on a parlé avec jean jacques et
j'ai bien senti qu'à un moment ils
voulaient vraiment s'approprier
l'histoire et je trouvais que c'était
vraiment bien ouais mais le film de
boisset c'était c'était une manne qui
tombaient du ciel pour mari l'écrivain
qui se disent à lui dit j'aurais baiser
les pieds à l'époque oui oui c'était une
année sabbatique ça permettait de
décrire le prochain libre donc c'était
génial il faut dire que je m'en moque et
un petit peu on peut vous le cinéma
c'était pas vrai cinéma français s'était
pas ce qui maintient la meute dans le
public vous adore tout de suite et la
critique a été effectivement
assez difficile avec vous pour des
raisons simples d'ailleurs parce que
pour la surcharge l'adverbe problème de
ponctuation fait des conneries en plus
des trucs de et vous dites d'accord je
suis l'ange exterminateur du point
virgule ce que je trouve assez drop il
faut dire aussi vous aimez pas tellement
enfin vous criez pas beaucoup dans le
milieu mais c'est vrai aussi que je
représentais quelque chose pour eux qui
cadrait pas vraiment sur dix entre
guillemets rock même si de toute façon
moi j'ai jamais porté bordeaux réunit de
santiago elle a dit quand je suis passé
chez rumeurs on va entendre le bruit de
ses bottes dans l'est toujours c'est
vrai et donc quand vous avez assimilé à
l'écrivain rock alors qu'en fait le ça
je crois que c'est très français le
s'intéressait plus à la personne qui à
son travail
j'ai vécu pas mal à l'étranger ça ne
rend pas ce genre de choses alors vous
n'êtes pas non plus un grand el-ater du
milieu ouvrier pas beaucoup avec le
milieu vous dites les snobs garant de la
belle littérature me font gerber
l'élitisme me révulse même
moi j'en veux pas mal à ces gens là
parce que je trouve que c'est les gens
qui freine la littérature donc les gens
qui écrivent bien je trouve que c'est
pas compliqué d'écrire bien écrire comme
mais ne pas être comme quelqu'un qui
tous les jours tous les matins ce
s'agenouille devant la ds littérature en
disant je fais partie du cénacle donc
vous va bien moi je trouve que la
littérature si on si on se bat pas la
littérature ça doit être une lutte moi
je me bats contre la littérature je veux
pas qu'elle me je veux que ce soit moi
qui comme latéral a tenu en respect quoi
c'est le seul moyen de la faire avancer
ça ne venait jamais eu de prix vous
connaissez la phrase de léautaud
phrase l auto mais si tout le monde
connaît tout écrivain qui acceptent un
prix est à jamais des confédérés vous
connaissez ça j'en ai eu un opus moment
donné il ya très très longtemps c'était
le prix libre même plus ce qu'ils
étaient avant vous c'est déjà bien oui
je reçois maintenant le collège gérard
lanvin pour le goût des autres le film
d'agnès jaoui jeanne lanvin bonsoir soit
alors on est content de vous avoir parce
que déjà au cinéma vous êtes quelqu'un
de rare alors en télévision c'est encore
pire oui non mais parce que je n'aime
pas trop expliquer mon travail je le
montre et les débats sur le métier
m'intéresse pas dit oui mais nous on
vous aime on a envie de vous le dire de
gros merci dans cette chine voit alors
le goût des autres dont le film d'agnès
jaoui scénario de djaoui et bacri
alors je connais pas je parle là
nedjaoui là excusez moi je ne connais
pas ni bacri j'étais bouleversé bravo
j'ai tout ce que je peux dire j'étais
bouleversé on s'entende ce film ça va
durer 48 heures l'histoire je crois que
c'est un film qui va voir un gros succès
et plein de césar dans un an voilà si je
voulais leur dire parce que c'est
vraiment un film qui m'a énormément
touché je crois que suis pas le seul
d'ailleurs parce que beaucoup de gens
autour de moi que ce soit lisabeth cas
où patrice carmouze qui n'ont vu ont été
aussi très très touché par ce film on
sort pas indemne quoi c'est quelque
chose d'important alors l'histoire en
gros vous les raconter je le raconte
raconter la tyrie non c'est un lycée
samse castella québec criq est un
industriel qui vit avec sa femme il a un
chauffeur qui échappe à un garde du
corps qui est vous parce qu'il doit
signer un contrat donc les assurances
demande qu'il soit protégé iran qui doit
apprendre l'anglais il rencontre clarac
épreuve d'anglais cannavaro est en fait
au début fais pas très attention à elle
et un jour en allant voir une pièce de
théâtre où joue une de ses nièces il
retombe sur elle joue bérénice et très
beau d'ailleurs on s'aperçoit à quel
point bérénice est un essai fantastique
rien n'arrive à aussi anne alvaro et
externe et là c'est le choc des mondes
c'est à dire s'ils ont rien à voir
ensemble elle vit dans un milieu
culturel de théâtreux lui y vit dans son
monde un peu difficile quoi et c'est la
rédemption par l'art lui levé rédemption
réel ce qui est encore plus intéressant
dans ce film c est qu elle commence à
porter un regard plus critique sur son
milieu et chacun prend conscience non
seulement de l'autre mais aussi de son
milieu voila voila vous l'avez très bien
c'est le même effet que c'est un film
sur le comportement et on les a priori
les préjugés qu'on peut avoir sur les
autres d'où le titre le goût d eau d un
retrait le goût d'aller vers et vous
vous êtes moreno dent sinon vous êtes le
le garde du corps engagés par les
assurances
c'est un oui un garde du corps qui
arrive dans une famille finalement parce
que alain chabat qui joue le chauffeur
joue aussi le chauffeur de la patronne
de madame castella donc c'est un type
qui arrive dans une dans une histoire et
qui doit commencer à s'adapter à cette
histoire il se fait profondément chez
parce que le boulot de garde du corps
est très chiant les militaires la police
avant il était dans la police et leur
raconte une histoire au début ce
histoire de la tortue c'est à dire que
deux tortues se dire que lui tu es dans
la police où il a donné sa dame parce
qu'ils avaient un gros bonnet voilà
c'est un mec qui est assez définitif sur
céline comportement parce que justement
il a pris des coups il a pris des coups
et notamment dans son boulot il ay là il
a pris des options qui n'étaient pas les
bonnes et s'est fait virer ou enfin
s'est fait virer parce qu'on l'a un peu
poussée dehors et donc il a un
comportement définitif avec la justice
pour lui la justice c'est de la merde et
il va être à l'intérieur de ceux de ce
film le seul personnage qui ne va pas
changer de l'histoire il a beau aller
vers quelqu'un ça ne va pas lui suffire
il va il va se refermer et ne va pas
aller jusqu'au bout de cette aventure
qui pourraient le changer et à la fin il
apprend quand même que lui avait quitté
la police le jour où ce gros bonnet
avait été protégé que son son collègue
tortue lui était resté
il trouvait que c'était une trahison est
en fait à la fin tortue arrête le mec
ouais donc en fait est ce que ce n'est
pas dire un peu la morale de la sphère
qu'il faut jamais quitté le terrain et
finalement il faut pas baisser les bras
et que c'est ça que ça veut dire parce
qu'on peut toujours trouver de bonnes
raisons de ne pas faire les choses
finalement oui sinon vous ne seriez plus
de télé ni moins du cinéma là il faut
continuer à se battre il faut pas
attendre que les autres ou z c'est un
parcours qu'on fait avec sa mentalité il
faut la faire accepter c'est tout bête
mais est-ce que vous finalement vous
avez pas le sentiment un petit peu de
gérer votre carrière un petit peu comme
moreno gère sa vie c'est à dire de temps
en temps vous casser là bas à la baule
et puis vous dit
je m'en vais j'en ai marre cinéma dans
il faut être clair avec ça j'ai fait des
enfants avec une femme que j'ai mené des
enfants que j'aime et je veux les
apprendre ses enfants je veux leur
donner la possibilité de me connaître
aussi comme papa comme j'ai cet avantage
là c'est que je suis heureux en famille
et donc je passe beaucoup de temps en
famille parce que ça me correspond et
c'était un désir absolu de ma part les
dix ans vous êtes parti des différentes
je suis parti là-bas j'ai des amis aussi
et je me dois de consacrer du temps ces
gens là parce que ça cesse et c'est mon
équilibre le cinéma prend beaucoup de
temps un film c'est trois mois un mois
de préparation avant si on en fait de
parents savent à 3 par an c'est qu'on se
fout un peu du reste quatre parents j'en
parle pas alors évidemment le le
résultat des courses c'est que quand
vous faites un film par an s'il marche
pas vous l'avez vous le prenez pleine
poire et quant aux en fait 4 vous avez
au moins la possibilité de penser qui en
a au moins deux ou un qui va être retenu
mais est ce que vous vouliez pas le
cinéma comme une combine vieux cinoche
m'est tombé dessus par hasard et je
l'utilisé comme une combine parce que je
veux pas devenir un fonctionnaire du
cinéma si vous êtes quand même un
rapport et que cinéma un peu on a le
sentiment des fois vous avez peur de
vous jeter à l'eau finalement non j'ai
sûrement peur de me jeter à l'eau met
fin en ce qui concerne mon travail mais
c'est vrai que c'est une combine à
partir du moment où je n'ai pas appris
quoi que ce soit on le faire j'étais
fort hein j'ai aidé et martin lamotte à
construire un café théâtre qui en
parlant c'est une réelle fierté
d'ailleurs le point virgule et en cela
je trouve que c'est une combine elle
m'est tombé dessus c'est une bonne
raison pour l'affermage la respecte tout
à fait tout à fait dit après après les
spécialistes on marche à l'ombre
j'aurais pu être entraîné dans le
tourbillon mais je sais relativiser
c'est à dire c'est pour ça que je dis ça
parce que
comme si vous avez eu peur de faire une
énorme carrière un moment non non j'ai
eu la chance simplement de free comptait
coluche pendant très longtemps une
dizaine d'années j'ai vu ce que c'était
que la célébrité à des degrés énorme ça
ne m'intéresse pas moi je veux
simplement être acteur je veux pas être
forcément car c'est un comportement le
star system cema un métier donc je n'ai
pas cette fonction là moi dans ma tête
comme étant le meilleur aussi aux césars
et c gepa il pas envie de faire un
concours et et
moi le fait de des tracteurs et si
possible un bon acteur me suffit
largement alors d'accord je vous fais
débuté au cinéma 177 vous n'aurez pas
l'alsace et la lorraine vous superbe
superbe collants blancs avec une belle
poutres apparentes et après bombay à
tous vos films et dix films une étrange
affaire moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié mais
un loup film avec ni siens un tir groupé
marshall ont des spécialistes en a parlé
et puis il ya eu quand même d'autres des
problèmes aussi c est moi vouloir toi je
te lancer dans la co écriture du film
est enfin j'aurais aimé que ce soit la
coécriture du film c'était avec votre
votre oui mais alors bon c'était un film
d'amitié mais oh j'ai été obligé de
l'écrire parce que patrice leconte qui
était prévu à l'écriture avec patrick de
vol n'ont pas trouvé la solution dans
l'écriture moi je me suis mis parce que
fechner me l'a demandé
sans savoir quoi que ce soit là dessus
j'ai quand même rendu 180 pages il m'a
dit c'est formidable j'avais pas de
recul je les crues jeu ceci dit je
revendique complètement ce film parce
que c'était un moment très heureux de ma
vie avec jennifer et l'autre problème
c'est lellouche quoi sert lui avait
consacré trois ans de votre vie oui j'ai
fait deux films avec lui vous avez fait
il ya des jours et des lunes et la belle
histoire et ça a été enfin la sortie
quoi ça c'est pas ça s'est pas bien
passé puisque le clan chouraqui vous
avez voulu vous prendre pour les
marmottes lelouch lui a dit prends pas
lanvin alors que vous avez consacré
trois ans autiste et pas très sympa
voilà j'ai pas [ __ ] la merde mais
c'est bien le problème courant déroule
avec moi
je suis quelqu'un qui dit les choses
parce que je n'ai pas honte à dire ce
que je n'ai pas non à penser donc sur le
sur le lascar en question bon j'étais
content qu'il vienne me chercher c'est
sûr à la résultante parfois forcément
convaincu par les films dont je me suis
tiré c'est tout bête par contre il ne
peut pas me reprocher l'ombre d'une
d'une erreur dans mon exactitude quand
je travaille et ce que je n'aime pas
c'est se venger à ce point là dans mon
dos donc je trouve que les mares manon
est un conte s'est bien passé d'ailleurs
c'est des films qui vous ont ramolli
pascal parce qu'après le rôle de jésus
dans la belle histoire et c'était dur un
peu pendant un moment
heureusement il deux films remarquables
et le fils préféré de nicole garcia qui
est un très très beau film et puis les
marmottes cac a bien marché aussi dont
elle est menée en 6e place mais ces
histoires anciennes et bien sûr vous
êtes un peu déçu quand même par là à
part le côté famille du cinéma vous y
croyez pas trop vous c'est pour ça que
vous êtes plutôt avec votre vraie
famille à la baule voilà m puis la
famille du cinéma faut pas compter
dessus dans la mesure où allait
s'adapter c'est si limité donc il vous
passez s'adapter une famille il faut en
connaître plus tôt plusieurs elle existe
mais c'est ce nom de par le film d'agnès
jaoui d'ailleurs cessé dé chapelles ans
et des machins autant être libre là
dedans et pas s'associer avec ce qui est
très bien dans le film c'est qu'à un
moment banal varrod clara lalala
l'actrice qui donne aussi des cours
d'anglais à un moment elles se rendent
compte que son milieu elle c'est ça qui
est bien dans ce film parce que se
foutent de la gueule de bakri qui était
un patron de pme c'est facile à un
moment elle se rend compte que dans son
milieu elle aussi à plat le combiné que
son copain ils essayent le petit le
petit peintre là ils essayent de vendre
des tableaux à castella elle dit que
c'est un peu malhonnête quoi donc c'est
la critique et des deux côtés c'est ça
qui est bien les intimes qui n'est pas
comme d'habitude nous les dimensionnelle
absolument absolument très ouvert mais
avec intelligence à vous sourit à la fin
du film quand même bref la marine de
chaleur russie ne reçoit maintenant le
philosophe bernard henri lévy pour la
parution chez grasset de son essai le
siècle de sartre alors le tour je
regarde le nouvel observateur et je vois
marqué l'événement lévis comédie dont
ils n'ont pas traîné là au nouvel obs je
sais que le lieu marche bien mais
l'événement lévis au bout d'une semaine
et en fait c'était marc levy pour si
c'était vrai donc été traduit en vingt
langues et vendu à steven spielberg pour
2 millions $ alors d'abord vous on
aurait dû dire l'événement bhl c'aurait
été plus clair et effectivement dans
l'observateur de la semaine suivante
bernard frank a dit si bien un événement
l'un l'un des sinon le meilleur livre de
bhl voilà donc les choses sont réglées
le nouvel axe vous rend l'hommage qu'il
vous devez le siècle de ça donc chez
grasset alors en quête philosophique sur
sur sartre c'est vous qui le disons
qu'il dit pardon en quête philosophique
beigbeder disait dans voici hier que
c'est une réhabilitation de mutual fait
le disait pas aussi clairement parce que
c'est beigbeder mais une espèce de
réhabilitation mutuelle tir vous vous
sortez du purgatoire en sortant de
sartre du purgatoire oui les choses
comme ça non parce que je n'avais pas le
sentiment d'être au purgatoire un peu
quand même pas tellement avant tant que
c'est pas grave
nous serrer un petit peu mais ça veut
dire qu'on était très haut pour avoir
des troupes turques at war mais je n'y
étais pas tout à fait en revanche c'est
vrai que sartre l'oeuvre de sa retraite
est obligatoire depuis 20 ans comme il
l'avait d'ailleurs prévu il savait il
avait dit ça oui enfin en gros il disait
il a dit je crois à benny lévy que quand
on meurt on en prend pour 20 ans ouais
il en a pris pour 20 ans et là dessus
voilà alors c'est étonnant parce qu'au
départ vous êtes plutôt du côté camus
malraux baudelaire est plutôt anti
sartrien au départ d'ailleurs j'y
retrouvais dans un papier sartre à
l'époque des nouveaux philosophes
pas en france mais dans un journal
italien qui s'appelle lota quentinois il
disait qu'elle vous philosophe c'étaient
des agents de la cia remarquent-ils la
lady d'autres gens avant vous mais oui
ce qui est formidable je vais avec ça
ces cadets des choses géniales et puis
de temps en temps il ya des bourdes
comme celle là à l'époque cela dit ça
m'avait je raconte ça dans le livre
d'ailleurs vous l'avez pris dans livre
cette information là soyez honnêtes dans
mon livre voilà je leur apporte
honnêtement et je rapporte honnêtement
que j'avais été partagée à l'époque
entre la consternation c'est jamais
agréable de ses retraités de l'agent de
la cia y est par un très grand
philosophe et en même temps un immense
éclat de rire voilà quand il l'a dit
tellement de gens agents de la cia et
bien vous est pris d'une passion
soudaine donc pour ça et c'est pas une
passion soudaine on joue on peut pas
dire ça c'est une passion ancienne
mais dont je ne prenais pas bien la
mesure c'est à dire que voilà je savais
comme je le dis dans l'avant propos du
livre je savais je crois d sa mort qu'un
jour ou l'autre j'écrirai je
rencontrerai de nouveau l'oeuvre de sa
manière un peu fondamentale alors on va
faire comme vous vous êtes commencer par
les femmes donc dans votre livre vous
parlez du rapport de alors j'ai un truc
du district et japon un sens et c'est
que des différentes versions de
dédicaces pour ses maîtresses il est
beaucoup de maîtresse un blizzard
membres ce n'était pas pas très bonne on
y est pas croyez que c'est un rapport je
sais pas moi je crois que ça n'a pas
tellement
oui moi non plus mais je crois savoir
que le que le désir n'a pas grand chose
à voir que ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler la beauté veut dire mendes
était follement séduisant et très laid
socrates était merveilleusement
séduisant il était laid sartre était
extrêmement séduisant et il était alors
il a séduit des générations de femmes et
d'une certaine manière noble enfin il a
été un des hommes les plus séduisants de
ce siècle avec cette bizarre avec cette
tête un peu voilà c'était une laideur
magnifique alors il ya un film qui va
sortir je passais vous le savez pas qui
va se faire avant de sortir c'est un
film de richard attenborough café gandhi
sur les aventures de sartre simone de
beauvoir et nelson algren donc espèce de
couple à trois comme ça dont on vous
parlait d'ailleurs parler d'eux je parle
pas du fait parce que ça je dis moi pas
du film et vous parlez de vivre d'amour
donc on craindrait elle y reprend pire
oui mais bien sûr je pars de l'histoire
d'amour parce que je crois que ça il ya
une espèce de poncifs d'abord
anti-pouvoir il est de bon ton depuis
très longtemps de dire que beauvoir est
une et une emmerdeuse antipathique un
sou sartre et c'est je crois le
contraire je crois que c'est un
personnage magnifique que sartre lui
dois énormément et que le deuxième sexe
est un des grands livres du 20ème siècle
et je crois aussi que l'histoire d'amour
sartre beauvoir est une belle histoire
c'est une histoire bizarre ça c'est sûr
avec notamment cette chose le mode hard
comme on dit c'est plus qu'un couple
matin c'est un couple littéraire puisque
je crois qu un des ressorts de la
jouissance sartrienne en gros sartre
coucher avec une femme et ils
jouissaient quelques heures après quand
ils couchaient la coucherie sur le
papier dans une lettre qu'il appréciait
simone de beauvoir il couchait d'abord
il jouissait ensuite mais par le
truchement du verbe du signifiant on
peut dire ce qu'on veut c'est quand même
une situation érotiquement intéressante
même si c'est pas ni votre manière ni la
mienne de pratiquer d'ailleurs que qu'en
savons-nous voit les choses de l'amour
mais je pense que c'est un couple très
beau et que c'est une belle histoire
d'amour et que le pouvoir était un
personnage
et c'est tout à l'heure qui est aussi
dans un amour de hatten sur 7 sur 7
avant qu'on craint le pire ça veut dire
ce que je crains tu mon agent je n'en
sais rien ne faisons pas procès
d'intention mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un
à nice mme contemporain une entreprise
d'aidé des nains qui nous entoure de
rabaisser les pas des grands hommes mais
en tout cas les les écrivains les choses
qu'on a écrites sur brecht les horreurs
qu'on a pu créer sur hemingway et on
peut s'attendre en effet à ce que les
nains les tarentules les hommes et les
femmes de ressentiment ne s'emparent de
sartre pour en faire je ne servais pas
les chiens pour aller renifler est allé
oui pour aller renifler les draps quoi
ce serait ce serait se serait nul on va
voir on va voir alors votre livre bon
bah c'est la thèse des deux sartre donc
c'est ce que le coeur du coeur du livre
avant le stalag et après le stalag alors
avant dans dix ans dahlia voir
nietzschéen vous dites découvreur du
vaccin anti totalitaire et après après
les stalags donc après la guerre
admirateur de staline en tous les cas
quand on pleure pas quand on te remets
tueur et faire de la scène du nom
soviétique entre les deux il ya une
stalag et là vous dites qui devient
humaniste il découvre et devient
progressiste y découvre l'homme avec un
grand h est pour vous face est votre
interprétation en tous les cas celle de
votre livre c'est le coeur du problème
c'est la cette espèce de
renversement du personnage finalement je
crois en gros si vous voulez mais pour
aller très vite mais contrairement à
l'idée dominante à l'idée reçue je crois
que tant que sartre mais ça dépasse le
cas de sartre c'est vrai d'autres
écrivains au xxème siècle tant que
sartre est anti humaniste c'est à dire
tant qu'ils ne croient pas encore aux
grandes idéologies
progressi sur l'avenir de l'homme sur la
construction d'un homme nouveau radieux
et ses îles et démocrates le jour où il
devient une manie c'est à dire commence
à entrer à accorder son crédit à la
fable d'un homme de meilleure qualité
alors il ya les dérapages que nous
savons sur lui c'est vous qui serez
tranquille et antitotalitaire
antitotalitaire quand ils entier
humaniste et qu'on est devenu l'année
parce que je crois que quand il est
intime à nice tu y crois à l'individu au
sujet il croit pas à l'homme majuscule
et puis en revanche quand il devient un
humaniste alors ils croient à une seule
espèce humaine réconcilie avec ça ils
croient mais c'est pas vrai c'est une
croyance voilà c'est surtout ses parts
et je crois que c'est de l'histoire du
20e siècle ça alors effectivement il
découvre la liberté avant le stalag et
après il dit libre oui c'est bien mais
pour quelque chose est il pour quelque
chose sont pas été pour rien voilà c'est
très clair dhr et ccta drm des chemins
de la liberté d c'est un des thèmes qui
anime ce grand lire ce monument
littéraire que sont les chemins de
liberté alors là il commence à dire
à se planter quoi c'est à dire les deux
passeurs plein de conneries les deux les
deux d'abord social et dénonciateurs du
régime soviétique donc david rousset il
dit on ne répond pas david rousset on
lui laisse gagner sa vie comme il peut
se trouvent les chances des total ce qui
est plutôt drôle il ya les deux il ya ça
et puis en même temps au moment par
exemple de la hongrie en 56 un texte
admirable qui s'appelle le fantôme de
staline qui est un texte anti stalinien
d'une figure c'est encore pire si vous
le dit
certes il est capable de dire tout et
son contraire en même temps ou à un an
d'intervalle est capable lorsque les
chars entrent alors en hongrie il est
capable de dire son horreur il est
capable de dire oui d'accord mais ça
empêche son mépris pour les communautés
imaginées imaginez un type qui soit
arrivée en 42 à paris et qui ai dit fais
les camps de concentration les les camps
de la mort et puis quand le fpi que l'on
ai dit en parlant de ce type là on ne
répond pas ce type là on lui laisse
gagner sa vie comme il peut je veux dire
kravtchenko
j'ai choisi la liberté sont
les traités d'agents de la cia comme
vous d'ailleurs parlé par les
communistes et il fait un procès au pc
et sartre même s'il a conscience que 35
audi pas complètement a pas complètement
tort il le laisse se faire lyncher par
appareil à l'époque mais d'abord il
d'abord je crois qu'il faut pas tout
mélanger et quel que soit moi j'ai écrit
il ya 20 ans annick c'est pas la
barbarie à visage humain juste au dessus
donc pas suspect a la moindre
complaisance à l'endroit de ceux qui ont
pu couvrir les crimes staliniens
n'empêche qu'on ne peut pas comparer je
reprends vos termes les camps de la mort
avec les crimes staliniens à ces deux
choses différentes premièrement
deuxièmement c'est vrai que sartre a dit
par exemple en 54 la liberté de
critiquer total en urs c'est vrai alors
il ya deux celui d'adrien anticommuniste
et un chien jeunes en jeu ne sort pas de
là je n'en sortirais jamais à nos
arguments
il faut essayer de comprendre pourquoi
moi j'ai écrit 6 175 pages pour essayer
de comprendre comment ce type formidable
cet homme libre ce théoricien de la
liberté ce mets ta fille ce philosophe
anti fasciste parce que je crois que
s'il ya un philosophe anti fasciste au
20e siècle et anti totalitaire c'est ça
s'il ya quelqu'un qui armera vos enfants
et les miens pour penser
l'antitotalitarisme de masquer sous
quelques villes âge qu'ils prennent
c'est là que nous devons sans grille
elle et vous comment expliquer que cet
homme-là qui a inventé cette philosophie
là qui a inventé tous les vaccins tous
les antidotes comment expliquer qu'en
effet il et puis alors chose pareille il
ya plusieurs explications j'en donne en
gros gens donnent trois ma femme il ya
600 pages en effet ya cette histoire de
stalag c'est à dire la découverte de la
communauté l'idée en hobereau que c'est
mieux d'être membre d'une collectivité
d'un groupe que d'être un individu il ya
deuxièmement un désespoir philosophique
le désespoir philosophique d'un homme
qui était parti avec l'idée qu'ils
allaient sortie qu'il allait en gros
démentir eagle démentir l'idée de la fin
de l'histoire et de la fana philosophie
recommencer la philosophie à 0 ça c'est
l'être et le néant et puis qui se rend
compte pour des raisons dans le détail
desquels on va pas entrer ici que cette
entreprise est vouée à l'échec et puis
là troisièmement une histoire qui
commence avec le surréalisme et qui
finit avec lui et qui a rapport avec ce
que j'appelle l'adieu à la littérature
et ça c'est l'histoire des moba hauts
revenus alors bon non seulement il s'en
prend aux gens qui dénoncent l horreur
soviétique mais enfin il admire castro
mao il déteste de gaulle dit il au temps
de pétain
dans la paix dans les damnés de la terre
dans la préface ils appellent aux
meurtres des européens alors
l'explication moi qui me semble la plus
claire dans toutes celles que voudrait
effectivement c'est la haine de soi oui
c'est à dire finalement cette espèce de
complexe éternelle que face à la classe
ouvrière qui est d'édifier on n'est pas
grand chose quoi mais c'est compliqué la
haine de soi c'est en effet la jeune
chèrement dossier d'air oui dans le cas
de il ya d'abord il ya aussi des
explications prosaïque il faut pas les
oublier non plus
quand il écrit la préface aux damnés de
la terre il faut voir aussi dans quelles
circonstances
on se trouve guerre d'algérie torture
d'état à grande échelle
quel des dizaines sans doute des
centaines de corps d'algériens jetés à
la seine est assassiné par la police
française et par le préfet papon c'est
dans cet état de rage et de colère face
à un état qui est en train de réinventer
des méthodes que l'on croyait d'oublier
que sartre écrit ce n'est pas une excuse
en effet on ne comprend rien à ce genre
de texte et à cette espèce de folie qui
s'empare de lui de démence parce qu'il
ya de la démence si on oublie cela et
puis il ya une autre chose ça c'est vrai
c'est la haine de soi la haine du
bourgeois en soit la haine de l'européen
en soit ce sentiment était que pardon je
vous coupe mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait
cette explication je crois que c'est
aaron qui disait il s'est pas engagé
pendant la guerre alors il s'est engagé
après bon mais ça c'est pas vrai place
mais c'est moi et sa bible mais ça comme
vous le savez je le démens c'est
justement voilà c'est le seul chapitre
proprement biographique de ce livre qui
n'est pas une biographie là je crois que
c'est une infamie sartre a commis plein
d'erreurs mais pas celle là encore
apparentes il s'est bien conduit pas
parler de la guerre donc pendant la
guerre il écrit dans comedia alors
évidemment il n'a pas fait de textes
collaborationniste parfait elle a quand
même écrit dedans il dit fait jouer les
mouches devant un parterre d'officiers
nazis non mais non non non non non non
il fait jouer les mouches devant la
jeunesse de paris devant des donc des
officiers nazis qu'alcoa en la jeunesse
de paris devant alexandre astruc devant
jean duvignaud devant moins jeunes jean
paulhan qui sort de là en disant j'ai vu
la première pièce avec un visa d'or j'ai
vu la première pièce anti vichyste de
l'occupation c'était un peu anti dans
titre de loris tout entier un ps comme
vous dites mais palpable enfin vous
hissez
les témoins les jeunes gens qui vont
voir cette pièce sorte galvanisé de
cette représentation jean cavaillès
quand il lit l'être et le néant qui est
probablement le dernier livre qu'il ait
lu avant de s'installer aux tno il était
déjà engagé dans la résistance mais
c'est un des derniers livres qu'il est
lui dans sa vie et on peut donc imaginer
qu'il y ait puisé d d d d un renfort
philosophique d'un master ii vous dites
moi une phrase comme de vous vraiment je
suis content de pouvoir vous en pas d'en
face vous dites depuis qu en reprochant
aux gens de n'être pas des héros quand
on dit ça pendant la guerre il a fait de
la résistance un peu à la noire s'était
pas il a un grand résistant c'est clair
dit depuis que reproche-t-on aux gens de
n'être pas des héros enfin séduit henri
amouroux ça non ainsi henri amouroux y
passe son temps à dire nous c'est les
français pendant la guerre c'est
terrible il pouvait pas tous est
résistant le glaive le bouclier on va
vous donner c'est henri amouroux oui je
connais rien brouille il ya deux choses
différentes dire en effet faire
l'impasse sur ce qui a été réellement
l'occupation sur la réalité du vichysme
c'est une chose accuser un intellectuel
en l'occurrence sarthe d'avoir été
d'avoir eu la moindre connivence
d'esprit ou d'actes avec un régime qui
n'a cessé de combattre dès le premier
jour en est une autre et c'est
dégueulasse le première chose j'en ai
marre de le répéter je leur ai fait
plusieurs fois premier show où il
attendait on vous a connu bernard on
vous a connu plus procureur mois dans la
barbarie française dans l'idéologie
française on va connu plus procureur je
me suis mis mais lui il était à l'école
à uriage l'école des cadres vichy
majorat je pense que votre mairie a eu
en alice lui vos bouquins pense que
beuve méry à uriage à alimenter la
machine idéologique du pétainisme me
verrier d'autres oui mais rien sur les
tigres et comme il était patron d'une
école quand les gars costauds riaj
l'école d'uriage fabriquer du pétainisme
est fabriqué de l'idéologie mais comme
avec la zakât - procureur mais je le
suis mais je le suis mais je suis tout
autant
idéologiquement sarthe fabrique une
philosophie de la liberté est une
philosophie de résistance l'être et le
néant c'est une philosophie une
résistance à tort comme avait d'accord
alors c'est le contraire d'uriage
deuxièmement le première chose qu'il
fait à peine débarqué à paris je veux
même pas m'énerver parce que c'est
tellement évident c'est de créer un
groupe de résistance qui s'appelle
socialistes et
libéraux plein de gens qui se faisaient
dans les bistrots pour créer des groupes
de résistance et il ya plein de gens qui
se réunissent dans les bistrots pour
créer des groupes de résistance et qui
finissait sous les coulées sous la
torture de la gestapo y compris dans le
groupe saft j'ai quand j'ai dit qu'on ne
peut pas reprocher un homme de ne pas
avoir été un héros jeudi surtout qu'on
peut pas lui reprocher ne pas être mort
sous la torture ya les camarades de
sartre qui sont morts sous la torture en
déportation et qui n'en n'ont fait ni
plus ni moins que lui voilà les droite
rigole spécial interview c'est fini
chers amis chers amis au revoir et à
demain 19 30 pour notre heure et demie
quotidienne d'exception culturelle
télévisuelle invité daniel prévost et
bernard rapp homme qu
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux